כן, אתה זוכר
בישינופקה
ינקו ברמן
זה היה זה שאמר לנו
שיש אפשרות
לנסוע
עלייה לכיוון
ארץ ישראל, עוד לא ידענו
המלחמה הייתה בעיצומה
אבל מה שהוא אמר
אסור לנו לספר
לאף אחד
מתארגנת קבוצה
בצורה בלתי לגלית
מפני שאם הרוסים אי אפשר לדעת
מה יחליטו מחר
אבל התנאי היה שלא נספר
לא להגיד לאף אחד
אפילו בבית
כאילו בבוקר לקום
ולברוח
זה היה כל כך לא נעים
כשפגשנו בערב
כמה היינו, 50-60
כי
איזה 60 היינו פחות
40 מישהו משהו פחות
30-40 מישהו
לא היה שם עומדים ככה
ו...
לביאלסטוק הגענו נסענו בבוקר
אני לא זוכר איך
אני לא זוכר איך הגענו לביאלסטוק
אני לא הגעתי
איתך ביחד
אני יצאתי קודם מפני שהרוסים
רצו אותי לגייס כבר
אז מוישי שוסטר
מוישי ינקו
אבל לא גם אני הייתי המועמד לזה שלושתם
רק את מוישי קיבלו
מוישי ינקו סלח להתגייס למשטרה
רק אותו קיבלו
כן, את שנינו לא קיבלו, זאת אומרת מתוך שלושה
ואמרו לי שאתנו יגייסו לצבא
אז אני
למחרת בבוקר קמתי
מפני ש...
ונסעתי לשדלץ
ולמה בשדלץ?
כי שבשדלץ היה שם אלברט
זה שהיה אצל מינסקי עם האופנוע
הוא שדלצאי
ושולם בילך
אז החלפנו לו את הבגדים
שולם בילך
היה טייס בצבא הרוסי
שהבצעים
כן, ומה שעוד
נסענו
אני גם עברתי
לשדלץ ושם היה איזה פוגרום
כזה ואני זוכר שאת שיירות
העקה זה היה
ובלילה
אז היה בלילה
שעלינו על רכבת
וברכבת הזו
נסעו כל כך הרבה חיילים
והיה מין בלאגן כזה
כן, ואנחנו
ככה נכנסנו
בלי רשות שם
עם כל... אף אחד
ביקש לו לא כרטיס לא שום דבר
נדחפת נכנסנו
ובאמצע הלילה אתה זוכר
מה שקרה שם בתוך האכרון
אתה זוכר את זה
היה שם איזה אונס
היו שם כל מיני
ככה היו בחורות פולניות
כן
ואנחנו נפגשנו
שם עם
עם כמה משפחות
מליטה
שיצאו מהמחנות
ואנחנו עזרנו להם
היו שם בנות בגיל שלנו
אתה זוכר איך קראו למשפחה
משפחת חייקין
חייקין
אתה צדק
הם שוררת
כן
ופתאום באמצע הלילה
שם התחיל
חיילים התחילו להתנפל
על השיקציה שם
היו כאלו צעקות
ואחד עם אגדך
עמד אלינו ואמר
אף אחד לא לדליק אור ולא שום דבר
יהיה
והלכו עם פנסים
והעירו לכל אחד בפנים
אז אני זוכר
אני זוכר על החייקין הזאת, אחת קטנה כזאת,
אז היא ככה נקשה, ככה התקרבה אליי,
כאילו שזה, אז הוא שואל ככה,
רובר הרוסי הזה, אנחנו אומרים אנחנו בעל ואישה.
אז הוא ככה אומר, כן, כן, אני יודע.
הוא כנראה היה יהודי,
כדי שלא עשה לנו שום דבר.
רוסים, היה להם דבר אחד טוב.
ברגע שאמרת שזאת אשתי,
מישהו אמר שזאת אשתי, הם לא התקראו.
אבל אחר כך, אחרי כמה שעות שנגמר שם,
ולא שכבנו על הרצפה שם,
ודרכו אחד על השני,
פתאום אני מרגיש שמישהו סוחב לי,
ולקח לי את התרמיל מתחת למרשות,
מתחת לראשי.
התחלתי לצעוק, אבל פתאום זרקו אחד לשני,
יש המון חיילים, דבר, אין לי מי לדבר.
אז, ואני ככה לא פחדתי,
ניגשתי בתחנה הראשונה של שהרכבת נמדה,
ניגשתי למפקד שם,
זה היה סך הכל רב סמר,
אמרתי לקחו לי את השמיכה,
ולקחו לי את התרמיל.
אז הוא אומר לי, מי לקח?
אז אני אומר, פה בקהון.
אז הוא אומר, בוא.
אני כבר הולך אחר,
הוא נכנס לקהון,
הוא ניתן צעקה, מי לקח ממני את התרמיל?
אז הוא מתחיל לדבר,
התחיל להוביל אותי,
תזהה, אני ראיתי מי יש לי פה עסק ככה.
אז כבר לא היה לי שום דבר,
רק מה היה לבפנים, את כל הדברים העיקריים,
וזה היה השעון, ואת נובע, וכמה תמונות בעצם.
זה היה עליך.
זה היה עליי, ואת היתר, הכל לקחו.
כן, אז אין כבר שום דבר.
אבל אם החבר'ה האלו היינו,
והיינו צריכים לבוא,
רכבות, אתה זוכר?
וזה בלילה, והם הסכימו לקחת אותנו,
זאת אומרת, הוא שתק,
ברגע שנעזור להם להמיס פחמים,
פחם.
אני עבדתי לילה שלם עם עת,
בשביל לזרוק פחם לתוך הקאצ'לוג,
וזה בהר.
ובבוקר קמנו,
ואחרי כך היינו כולנו שחורים.
קמנו אחד על השני וצחקנו,
אה, כמה שתה שחורים, אה, כמה שתה שחורים.
היינו כולנו שחורים, נשאר רק שמה, כן?
עד שהגענו ללובלין, כן?
ומלובלין, שמה נפגשנו עם ינקו ברמן,
שמה עם אשו,
ושמה, אתה זוכר מה שקרה משם?
שמה הייתה ציוויה לובטקין כבר ו...
כן, דיברנו עם ציוויה לובטקין ועם אנטק, כן?
אבל מה ש...
שמה פתאום הדביקו לנו,
זה זוכר, לי הדביקו שלוש משפחות.
אחד היה כזה, ככה,
אה, כל כך לא סימפטיים אם הם היו ככה,
עם זאב, עם כל מיני ככה דברים,
כי נראה שהם נתנו כסף,
ובשביל כסף היינו צריכים
לעזור להם לבוא איתנו,
ואנחנו עליו היינו עלייה בית, כן?
כמה שלא היה שם אחד,
כמה שלא סברתי אותם, כן?
רק בשביל עצמם,
הביאו שוקולד למקור זה,
הם לא הציעו שום דבר,
היה להם כסף, כן? וזהו זה.
אני חושב שעד בוקר יש לך כמה שם
להתפתח, אני אומר.
אני, הדביקו 2 משפחות מהליטאים.
מהליטאים כאלה שיצאו ממכנות,
ומשפחה הזו הייתה,
משפחת חייקין הייתה אמא
ו3 בנות או 4 בנות,
אני כבר...
מאוד נחמדות, אני זכיר את זה.
מאוד נחמדות,
הם היו בין הבודידות שידו עברית.
כן, דיבר לנו, כן, כן.
חייקין ידעו עברית, הם דיברו עברית.
כן, מאוד נחמדות.
ויועד שאנחנו היינו צריכים לנסוע
כמו קליטים מיוון,
אז בא יוון יהודי,
בבנים מדברים עברית, דיברנו עברית. ומי שמא יהודים שלא ידע עברית, אז הוא דיבר יקומפו כאן מישהו מה היה.
עברנו הירות, ואיפה שהרכבת נמדה ליותר, ללילה, ליום, ירדנו, אני חושב שהיינו בצ'רנוביץ', ואחר כך אנחנו הגענו באמת לאומנה.
זה באמת, אני חושב, הגענו בהתחלה, זה היה, וזה ביום שישי, או בשבת זה היה, אבל ביום ראשון, אני זוכר את זה, שביום ראשון היו צריכים להקים שער לבנש.
איזה שער, אני לא יודע. שער עצום כזה, ו... איפה זה הומנה? זה על הגבול של...
הומנה על הגבול בין צ'כיה לאונגריה ופולניה, זה קרוב אחד לזה.
ועבדנו עם איטים לחפור, וכל, כל, כל העיר שם עמדו מסביבנו, והם דיברו, אלה הם יוצאי מחנות.
כן, אני אומר, שהיה יום ראשון, הם לא עבדו, ורק לנו, והבטיחו לנו ערוכה.
ואני, מי נעשה לכם את הערוכה? איך הם קראו לנו דפ...
והייתם עלייה בית, אבל מה הייתם... כן, אבל אנחנו היינו, היינו כאלו שקראו לנו business, שאנחנו ברחנו מהמחנה.
דפורטנטים, דפורטנטים.
דפורטנטים, כן. שאנחנו בורחים ממחנה ריכוז.
לא, אבל...
אז רחמו עלינו, זאת אומרת, אנחנו יצאנו, היינו בעיר, הסתובבנו, ו...
ושם היה כבר מישהו, ובכל אופן, לעלייה בית היו אנשים.
בכל מקום, היה מישהו שקיבל אותנו.
שקיבל. אז הם אמרו שזהו, ושאלו, אתם רוצים לבוא, תקבלו אוכל ומה, בסדר.
אז אני זכר שגמרנו.
וכסף לא כבר?
לא, לא.
הקמנו את השער עם...
היו שם מפרחים.
דרך אגב, ב... מתי זה היה? זה היה במרץ.
מרץ.
זה היה במרץ, עוד היה קריר.
45'.
כן, במרץ, 45', כן.
אז זה היה אז, מרץ 45'.
ומשם נסענו ליתוקאי.
ליתוקאי.
תזכר את ה...
ליתוקאי, רצינו, היה נחל לפני ליתוקאי, רצינו לבוא, אבוסים אומרים, תעבדו פה לעזור, להקים את הגשר.
בערב נביא אותם.
הם הביאו אותנו, אבל עבדנו מהבוקר עד הערב.
עבדנו איתם, הביאו אותנו את הנחם.
וזה, זה לקח ימים.
אני זוכר את הלילות שאנו שוכבים על ה... בתוך הקרונות.
ושמה, היה, לא, לא, מישהו, זה הייתה מלחמה.
אז הגויס היו באים עם, עם השלים האלו, חזירים היו.
והיית חזירים, השכבנו.
השכבנו, והרכבת, אני זוכר, פה, פה, פה, פה, פה.
וזה, זה התמזג עם השפה ההונגרית.
פה, פה, פה, פה, צ'ה, צ'ה, צ'ה, צ'ה, צ'ה, צ'ה, צ'ה.
והחזירים, והסירחון, והרכבת.
אנחנו אף פעם לא ידענו אם הרכבת נוסעה בכיוון שרצינו או לא.
כן.
בדיוק, ככה וזה.
והיו צריכים לא להתבלט.
חז וחליל, אבוסים היו תמיד עוברים ככה.
והיו מחפשים עריקים.
רגע, על קרציש לא הייתם קורנים?
לא, לא, איפה לא.
היה לנו כסף וגם לא, לא.
זה היה מלחמה ממחר.
כל הרכבות היו צבאיים.
היה צבא.
כל היה צבא, שום דבר לא.
זה רכבת מסע או צבא?
כן.
עכשיו, האם אתה זוכר?
האסור היה לנו לשמוע רוסית ולחדו לחייך.
כאילו שאנחנו לא מבינים רוסית.
כן, כאילו שלא מבינים רוסית.
זה היה הדבר.
אם היה מתגלה שמבינים רוסית,
הם היו עריקים מהצבא.
ואז היו עוצרים אותנו.
ואז בלי שום בעיר.
אז אמרנו, אני זוכר שעברנו את
וואלס, מישקולדס, צ'ופ,
והגענו לדברצין.
עכשיו, בדברצין היה לי סיפור.
יעדו מהרכבת,
ושם היה לי כתובת,
אני זוכר עד היום.
יושב קיראי היה צאוצא.
עכשיו,
לך תדע שבאונגרית,
אם אתה אומר את זה רגיל,
אף הונגרים עוברים.
הוא אומר, הוא פורז בצחוק,
ובורח ממני.
אז התחלתי לנגן את זה.
אני לא כל כך מוזיקלי.
אז עד שאחד הבינו אותי,
והביא אותי לכתובת.
עכשיו, כל הדברצין
הייתה מופצצת.
לגמרי.
עכשיו, בדברצין כבר לא היה שלק.
שם העיקרים כבר יצאו
לחרוש את הסלון.
בפרולין עוד היה שלק.
ושם אפשר היה לקנות,
המקום הראשון שראינו שפע.
לחם בפירות.
פתאום פתחנו את העיניים עלו.
לא היה לנו מה לאכול.
אנחנו פשוט עוד ככה בדרך.
ומשם,
אני זוכר שעברנו באמת
לקלוש, כלוש ברות.
קלוש, כלוש ברות.
ואחר כך, איך קוראים, עם הרפית,
הגענו...
לא, הרפית, הרפית זה עוד לא היה.
הרפית יצאנו מבוקרש.
גם לשם זה היה.
ברכבת נסענו.
התפלוישתי.
כבר ברומניה.
עכשיו הגענו לבוקרש.
הגענו לבוקרש.
הייתה לנו בעיה.
אנחנו באנו עם מגפיים, עם זה.
ובבוקרש הלכו עם חליפות.
מה זאת אומרת עם זה? מגפיים, זה מה?
לבושים, כאילו באנו מהכפור.
לא, זה היה חורף, כן.
עכשיו,
בבוקרש הלכו עם חליפות,
ואמרו אם אנחנו נלך עם המגפיים,
א' שהרוסים יצרו אותנו,
יוריד לנו את המגפיים, אם הם צריכו.
ספגי, ספגי.
או שיכולים לאסור אותנו.
עשרה חליפות.
איזה חליפות קנינו? חליפות מנייר.
בבוקרש היו חליפות מנייר.
זו הייתה חליפה יפהפיה.
רק בגשר...
הם רימו.
כאילו, אנחנו לא הבנו.
היינו התמימים.
שם קנית את החוצה.
היינו כל כך, צחקנו מהם,
ובסוף הם סידרו.
כן, ממש צחקנו מהם,
איך שהם ככה ורוצים.
ראינו ש... אמרו, וראינו,
היה לנסה, ראינו מי יש לנו עסק.
אבל, אך...
איך שחשבנו, לא חשבנו
שעד כדי כך. הם היו מבקשים,
למשל,
דבר שיכולת לקנות בשביל
עשרה לי,
אז הם מבקשים 120.
אז לך, אז לא נעים,
אתה אומר 60. או 40.
מיד, קודם הוא מתחיל להגיד,
ונח, ונח.
עד ש...
ואנחנו צחקנו.
הוא מנהיג שהוא נשווה
בחיי אשתו והילדים,
זאת אומרת, זה שקר.
זה שקר.
גם היהודים.
אבל שמה, שמה כבר
היה מחסור. פעמיים בשבוע,
היה מותר להם,
זאת אומרת,
מרמליגה ולפטה,
זה היה חלב עם מרמליגה.
אנחנו כזרים,
בכלל לא היה לנו את הזכויות,
והיו שם,
איך קוראים לזה,
הלגיונרים האלו,
הם היו אנטי-סמיטים,
והם כמה,
הרביצו לחבר'ה שלנו,
סתם תפסו.
ושם היינו,
היינו באיזה מקום,
אתה זוכר, את הרחוב היה?
בצ'ישמיג'ו.
והיינו, התארגנו בקיבוצים.
אני זוכר רק את הרחוב,
של, של, של,
של, של האלו,
שם, קוד שדה פיאטה.
אה, זה בגדל בקדל בביתך,
בגדל בגדל בביתך.
מה זה, מה זה?
זה רחוב מסלחים לשאוזונות.
אבל שם היה לנו, אתה זוכר,
כשהגענו לבוקרס,
אז פתאום,
חבר אחד שהכרנו אותו,
היינו איזה שבוע ימים יחד,
ופתאום,
הוא מת. אתה זוכר?
זה אני לא יודע.
הלכתי, הלכתי, אז היה
בבית קברות,
בבית קברות של ספרדים,
ואף פעם לא ידעתי מה זה.
או, היה פעם ראשונה
בחיים, שראינו שיש שני בתי
קברות של אשכנזים.
אז איך אתה לא זוכר, ואני זוכר,
שכמעלה חף ייצא ולך,
וישקיבו אותו, זאת אומרת,
שם קברו אותו,
אף אחד לא יודע,
בקושי ידעו מה שמו,
הוא עבר את,
הוא עבר את כל,
הוא היה במחנה,
ועד שפתאום, מחלה רגילה,
ונפתח. אני זוכר,
מי שאומרו ככה, והוא כבר
היה חבר, היה בגיל שלנו ככה.
זה עשה קצת רושם,
אמנם אחרי שעבר,
אני זוכר, בית הקברות היה כזה
שקט ויפה, והיו שם
קברות אחים כאלה גדולים,
ואנחנו השארנו אותו, אני לא יודע
בכלל אם השאירו שם השם,
והיה לנו
עוד דבר אחד משם,
שחזרנו,
אני זוכר את,
נו, את, מה השמוע,
את הסופר הזה,
אני לא זוכר,
כן, מה שהיה עם ציוויה
לבית כינור, זה, זה, זה,
הפוליטרוק של, כן,
נו,
מהצ'ינצ'ים,
אבא קובנר, אבא קובנר, כן,
היינו עם, כן, המאגן הראשי,
כן, אז ישבנו שם,
עם אבא קובנר, עם ציוויה,
ועם אנטק, ואני זוכר,
אז התחשמתי באמת עם אבא קובנר,
כזה עם המאגן,
איך שהוא דיבר, בצורה כזאת,
עם משלים,
עם מיטים,
הוא הרבב,
הוא עשה עליי רושם, כן,
והוא אומר,
מה שעברנו, ומה שיש לנו להקריף,
כן, ושם,
חוץ מזה, אנחנו ידענו שאבא קובנר,
הוא היה
מפקד קבוצת פרטיזנים יהודים
מסביבות וילנה,
לא, אני התחשמתי במיוחד
מהשיחות שלו,
אבל העברית שלו,
כן,
ואני מוכרח להגיד,
את אנטק,
ואת ציוויה,
הם היו ככה קצת,
פגשנו אותם בכל מיני מקומות,
בבוקרסט,
היו לנו בבוקרסט,
שם היינו,
בבוקרסט היינו כמה חודשים,
קרוב לשלושה חודשים,
שלושה חודשים,
עשה מלחמה לגמרי,
כן, ועברנו, היו לנו כל כך הרבה,
אבל זה כבר היה, אלה מין דברים,
שכבר לא היו,
זאת אומרת, כאילו שהרגשנו,
מתחילים לחיות, היה לנו כבר
קצת כסף, לכל אחת נתנו
כמה פזות,
לא, חוץ מזה,
קלעים, כסף נתנו, ואפשר היה לצאת
לבודיגה,
עם איזה מין מזנון כזה,
שאפשר היה לשתות שפריץ,
שפריץ, כן, שם למדנו,
מה שאתה יודע,
בכל אופן, מה שהתברר לנו,
הלו הגענו לבוקרש, ברדיי,
שנוכל לעבור
דרך הודסה, לנסוע
לארץ ישראל,
עד משם המסף
עשפו אותנו,
ובאמת אבא קובנר
היה זה שהוא אומר,
אין מעבר, ואנחנו צריכים לנסוע
חזרה,
אנחנו צריכים לנסוע חזרה
לאוסטריה, ומאוסטריה
לעבור,
לעבור איטליה,
כן, בינתיים כבר נגמרה מלחמה,
את זה שכחתי,
בשמיני למאי, נגמרה מלחמה,
וזהו, נגמרה מלחמה,
ו...
אנחנו צעדנו ברחובות בוקרשת,
עם דרור אבונים,
וכל הדוות הציוניות,
הלכנו שם, אני זוכר אפילו את
את ההצגות משם,
טוב,
זוכר אפילו,
עם לקולנוע,
ומתחילתם מהבית,
מהבית יצאנו בהתחלת
מרץ,
סוף אברואר,
או סוף אברואר,
אז מרץ סוף אברואר,
כן, סוף אברואר, כן, כן,
אז טוב,
מתחילים לנסוע חזרה,
עכשיו, בעוד משהו,
כשיצאנו מפולין,
האדמה הייתה קפואה,
הגענו לאונגליה,
השלגים בצ'כיה התחילו להפשיר,
כשהגענו בגבול הונגליה,
גבול רומניה,
כבר חרשו את השדות,
ברומניה,
כבר נפטו התפואות,
התפיל להיות ירוק,
לתוך שבועיים,
בדרך חזרה, כן,
מה שאני זוכר בדרך חזרה,
היינו, עלינו על הרכבת רפית,
ושם היה צריך לשלם,
הרבה כסף,
כן, מה אתה זוכר מזה?
בדרך חזרה, אני הייתי
ברותו ראש קבוצה,
ואנחנו היינו איזה 25 או 30 איש,
כולם אחד אחד בחורים,
שהיינו צריכים גם חלק,
להישאר בכל מיני תחנות,
עכשיו,
משם יצאנו עם הרפית,
בוקרשט-קלוש,
שזה בערך אלף קילומטר,
מה זה רפית?
רפית זה רכבת מהירה,
וזה כבר,
אזרחים קונים כרטיס,
זה לא היה כבר מבולגס,
הוא עושה את זה ב-12 שעות,
בוקרשט-לוקסוס,
ובעיקר נשאו באנשי צבא קצינים,
לנו החבר'ה השיגו,
היה לנו יהודים,
מתם הצלב האדום הבינלאומי בבוקרש,
השיגו לנו קרטיסים,
בדרך,
כמו שאנחנו יושבים,
עוברים מבלשים ובודקים,
ואחד הכיר אותי,
מפני שאני ישבתי שבועיים בבית הסוהר בבוקרש,
אני ומוניק אחד,
ישבנו בבית הסוהר,
יצאנו לקנות בשביל המטבח,
מצרכים,
ותפסו אותנו,
הוריד אותנו מהטראמבי,
ועד שמסרנו,
איפה אנחנו נמצאים?
המזל שלנו היה,
שישבנו בבית הסוהר של הרומנים,
בקליב הקרשט,
בפרופקטורה,
הרומנית,
אז בת קסם,
ועברנו פתק,
לחבר'ה שלנו,
ואז הם דאגו להוציא אותנו.
רגע, אבל...
והוא הכיר אותנו,
הבלש הזה,
אז הוא אומר,
אלה לא דפורטנטים,
אלה כנופיות,
אנחנו צריכים לעצור אותם.
והוא טלפין מרכבת,
טלפין לתחנה הבאה,
מפני שהרפיד היה עוצר
בתחנות מסוימות,
נדקה שתיים ונוסעה הלאה.
אז הוא טלפין ששם יחכו
ויוצאו אותנו.
אנחנו ברכבת הכרנו יהודי,
שעבד בצלב האדום הבינלאומי,
גם כרומנים,
שהוא ידע את השפה,
יותר מאיתנו.
אני זוכר את היהודי הזה,
הוא נתן כסף...
חכה, תן לי לגמור, אחר כך תסתים.
היהודי,
סיפרתי לו את הסיפור,
והם השגיחו עלינו.
אז הוא אומר, חכה, חכה,
אנחנו לא נוריד אתכם.
אנחנו מגיעים לתחנה הבאה,
דפורטנטים החוצה.
אז התחילו,
אז הוא אומר, תרדו.
הוא ירד ראשון,
והוא התחיל להקים צעקות, מה זה,
שלושים בחורים,
יש להם עשרים ותשע כרטיסים,
אז מורידים את כל השלושים.
הוא בלבל אותם, הם לא ידעו בשום מה
הורידו אותנו.
אז הוא בלבל אותם, הוא אומר מפני שלא,
אין לכולם כרטיסים, אז מורידים את כל הקבוצה.
ואנחנו נשכבנו לפני הרפיד,
הרפיד לא נסע,
שיעלה על גופינו.
העיקר, הם ראו שהם לא יכולים,
להזיז את הרפיד, אז הוא אומר,
הקונדוקטור, טוב, והוא רומני,
טוב, הוא תיקף,
הוא שילם לו.
אז הוא תיקף, הוא אומר, תספרו,
הוא ספר עשרים, שאנחנו כבר ראינו
כל השלושים בפנים.
אז הוא אומר, טוב, בסדר, נסענו,
וכשהגענו לקלוש,
לידוש הרפיד, אנחנו שם
התחבנו, שלא, אבל
לשם האלה לא ירוצו אחרינו.
זה היה סיפור.
כן, ומשם, טוב,
הקבוצה, כן.
שניים יצרתי מישינובקה?
שניים, לא, רק שניים.
שנינו, מישינובקה
יצאנו רק שנינו.
זה היה, זה היה ליאה בית,
אסור היה לספר, זה עוד היה
בסודי סודות.
בתוך המלחמה.
וגם חנן ידע.
טוב, ותעלה, אבא סיפרתי
ביבי בליל, לא, לא יכולתי לברוע
מי אבא, אבל אמרו
לאף אחד, ביבי בליל סיפר.
טוב, אבל זה...
לא יספרו לרוסים, שלא יוודאו.
אחר כך, אני לא זוכר
עם מי אני הייתי,
כן, אני לא זוכר,
כן, אבל שהגענו
ליד גבול אוסטריה,
איפה שיש המעבר.
אז אני אומר לך, זה אזור גראט,
עוד אמרנו, אנחנו נוסעים,
זה מקרץ, זה קרץ.
כן, בסדר, אז
שם היינו צריכים לעבור
ל...
בפויסברג. כן, לאזור
האנגלי. אזור
האנגלי. אזון האנגלי.
זה היה מחולק בין הרוסים לבין האנגלים.
כן. אז...
זה היו, ואמרו,
מוכרחים לעבור את הגבול.
כמובן שלא היינו יכולים לעשות את זה,
אז לעשות את זה בלילה,
באיזה, דרך איזה
חורשה. אבל שם היו לנו
מדריכים פה. שם כבר היו
מדריך אחד. שם היה זר מנחן,
שישב שם. מדריך אחד, כן.
והוא, הייתה לו איזה שיקסה, והשיקסה
הייתה מעבירה איתה קבוצות. כן, אז
הלכנו, הלכנו
בלילה. אני זוכר
שזה... הולכים, הולכים, הולכים,
ולמדו שמחים, ואומרים,
פה עברנו, פה עברנו.
דרך איזה חוטאי, או דרך איזה משהו,
בבית פרטי, שם, אני יודע,
שם עליה יד איזה, בכפר שם
עברנו. חורשות, בכפדים. כן. חשבתי
שכבר הכול, פתאום,
במקום
האחרון, צעקה,
סטוי, ברוסית, עמוד.
ברוסית, הופה. נתפסנו.
ככה עומדים מולנו,
ועם רובים נתפסנו.
נתפסנו,
מה יש, מה להגיד,
טוב, אחד לוקח אותנו
בחזרה, לקחו אותנו...
את כל הקבוצה, או כל השלושים?
לא, אני...
לא היינו שם השלושים.
אני חושב שהיינו... לא, זה היו קבוצות קטנות.
קבוצות קטנות. אני חושב שהיינו את זה...
חודשה, שישה... כן, את זה,
שמונה איש, ועברנו,
בנשיא יותר, ולקחו אותנו
לגרץ, באמת,
אני חושב, ושם, היה שם...
לא טוב, פויסבארד.
כן. והכניס אותנו לאיזה מה...
קונו היה שם, באנו,
הביאו אותנו לפני
הקומנדנט שם, היה רוסי, חייכה
צבא. הוא פוגרניסנו, הוא היה איש
מישור. כן, והוא שאל אותנו,
הוא רצה לראות אם אנחנו לא
עריקים מהצבא. כן, אבל...
בגלל שצבא דיבר
איתנו מעט מאוד, ואחר כך
אמר, קח אותם,
הוא דיבר, והוריד אותנו
למרטף, למטה,
נעלו, זהו,
שוכבים למטה, על הרצפה,
מחרד בבוקר,
כן, וזה...
כלום עליו לא היה, לא סמיכה, לא שום
דבר. שוכבים למחרד בבוקר,
זה כבר היה די מומחר,
בשמונה, מביאים אותנו שוף
לאיזה קומנדנט אחר,
שם יושב. אבל
הוא היה יהודי.
הוא הבין מה שהולך פה.
הוא ידע. אני חושב שהוא
ידע. אז הוא התחיל... איזשהו זעומן הזה
סיפר לנו שהוא יודע.
הוא התחיל לשאול
אותנו שאלות, ולא נתן
אפילו לגמור את התשובות, כאילו שהוא
כבר אמר, הוא אומר, תראה,
אני לא לוקח אתכם עכשיו, לא
סייר אתכם, נשאר, יכולתי לשלוח
אתכם עם ההישלון שיוצא,
הוא רמז. חזרה.
כן. אבל,
אוי ובוא אליכם, אם אתם
תנסו עוד הפעם,
לעבור את הגבול.
אם אתם תתאפסו פעם שנייה, אוי ובוא אליכם.
עכשיו, זה היה יום ראשון
בבוקר.
וזה, זלמן אומר,
ביום ראשון,
המשתקרים.
היום זה אנחנו חייבים לעבור.
ביום. התחלנו ביום לעבור.
עכשיו, הגבול
היה מסומן. לא, לא הייתנו.
הגבול היה מסומן. היה שם.
היה סכן שם.
עמדת תצפית פה, ועמדת תצפית פה.
זה הכל צבא, כן.
זה לא היה מתוקד.
זגזג. זאת אומרת, איפה שלא הלכת,
התקלת בי שתי עמדות.
ושם היו חורשות.
אבל גם בלילה.
זה היה גם בלילה.
בלילה השני. לא.
לא, לא, לא, רובה, אתה טועה.
אני זוכר שהיה חושך
שיצאנו פעם שנייה.
והיה אחר הצהריים, ואנחנו הגענו
כבר פתאום, יוצא
מביזה גוי, מאיזה כפר,
בא ובילא עם בנות.
זה היה ביום, בנפנות ערב.
והתברצר אותנו שוב.
ואז נתנו
לא הוא נתן.
אבל אתה טועה.
זה היה בלילה,
ואני זוכר את זה, טוב.
והלכנו,
היה שם
היה שם האחת,
שבכוס שהוא הלך מרחוק,
אבל אנחנו במקרה, בלילה,
נפגשנו עם
קבוצה, איזה שלוש, ארבע
בנות גרמניות,
שהם הלכו לכפר שלהם.
וזה היה חושך.
והם עוד שאלו
ככה, והתחילו להתבדח
איתנו, יודעים ככה
אמרנו, לא יודעים ככה, עשינו ככה
שלא יודעים, והם קצת צחקו
עלינו.
וגם, זה כבר היה
מאוחר בלילה, אני חושב,
פתאום,
שוב, מאיזה שמקום,
מבצבסים החיילים
האלה עם הקובעים,
ועמוד.
רובים מולנו, עמוד.
ופעם השנייה,
ואחרי שהחלטנו פעם שנייה לבוא,
אמרנו, שרק לא ניפול פעם שנייה
בבידי שוב
הקומנדנט הזה.
משום איך מהחבר שלנו התחיל לפקות.
כן, היה שם איזה
בת אחת שם,
ואיזו בחורה אחת,
שהיא, אני שומע, זאת היא,
כן, הפולניה הזאת,
מקרקוב, כן, איזה.
אז פתאום,
האם, אלו,
השיקסס האלו, הם יצאו וככה
התקרבו אלינו, הם בחורים
מה יש לך?
היא התחילה לצחוק
עם החייל, מה יש לך?
מה אתה עושה את עד מכך?
אלה הם אנשים שהולכים, מה?
תן להם לבור. בגרמנית, כן.
תן להם לבור פה, לכפר.
אז אחר כך הוא אומר,
מה יש להם? זה הוא אמר ברוסית.
מה יש להם?
אז אם לא הבינו, אז הוא אומר, מה יש להם?
אז התחילו כולם
להוציא מה שיש להם.
לי היה את נובע, מה כבר היה לי,
זה היה הכי...
כל אחד נתן,
הוא אפילו ככה
ירש ליריוטים אלי למעלה,
עברנו.
אודות לשיקסס.
כן, אודות לשיקסס.
לזה בדיוק עשה עליי רושם,
שהיא צריכה להתכנן בפני הרוסי,
כן, שאתה יודע, הגרמניה,
שהתנו לנו לבור.
עברנו,
אבל מיד עצרו אותנו אנגלים.
אתה זוכר?
מיד נפרנו,
עצרו אותנו אנגלים,
עלות.
הביאו איזה מכונית מסע,
לעלות למכונית מסע, עצרו אותנו.
כן, אתם עצורים.
עלינו, נוסעים, נוסעים,
נסענו די הרבה,
ופתאום הגענו
למחנה,
מחנה צבאי.
איפה? בטרוויזו כבר זה היה.
זה היה קרוב לאלפים, כן.
קרוב לאלפים, ואיפה שהבריגדה עמדה.
כן, נסענו די הרבה.
די הרבה.
עוד שם עוד לא עסקנו
עם הבריגדה. אחר כך
הבאנו לבריגדה.
גם
התייצבנו
בפני שם איזה מפקד,
הם מדברים אנגלית, לא הבנו שום דבר.
היו בינינו ככה,
שהבינו ככה קצת אנגלית,
והם היו, כן, נתוגם אמין.
אז אמרו, אתם עצורים,
ומה שיש לכם לעשות,
נתנו לנו,
לכל אחד, לנקות את המחנה,
את הבתי שימוש,
את העבודות הכי מלוכלות.
כמה ימים.
ואתם עצורים.
אני זוכר שפתאום,
החבר'ה,
אני לא יודע מי העין זה בא,
שם זה כבר היה יותר,
שם ראינו כבר יהודים שבכלל לא הכרתי אותם.
שם היו עוד יהודים.
והם התחילו להתמרד,
לא רוצים לנקות את הבתי שימוש,
לצבא.
הקימו מאומה,
אחר כך,
זה לא לקח הרבה זמן,
אוכל נתנו,
בא,
בא מאיזה מסעית,
צבא,
ואומרים שצריכים לקחת אותנו לעבודה.
טוב,
אנחנו היינו בידיהם.
היינו בידיהם,
אבל שוב,
לוקחים אותנו לעבודה.
לוקחים אותנו לעבודה,
אנחנו עולים,
אנחנו עולים
unky plane.
אנחנו עולים על המכונית מסע
לתום סגרו לנו את הברזנט,
ועולה אחד,
ואומר לנו,
תדעו לכם,
עכשיו,
אני יהודי,
ארץ-ישראלי,
ואתם מכוסים ואנחנו נוסעים לעבודה.
בתור אחד כזה הוא גילה שלא תעשו רעש.
היינו מכוסים בברזנט ואני לוקח אתם לעבודה ואתם אומרים שאתם אזרחים, לקחנו אתכם לעבודה.
ארץ ישראל לא זרמה, אני לא זוכר.
אבל שם באותו מחנה עבדנו, אבל שם כבר בבוקר, הגישו לנו אורחת בוקר, דייסה מיתוקה.
רגע, רגע, עד שהגענו למחנה הזה, אז נסענו איזה יום שלם בתוך מסעית כזאת צפופה שמה.
כביש משובה.
כביש משובה שמה.
בערים, בערים למעלה.
אז שפתאום נכנסנו למחנה.
איזה זה היה יום הראשון אני חושב מכל הנסיעה.
מדברים עברית, זה הכל הבריגדה.
הבריגדה.
והתחלנו, אני חושב שקלקלנו את, אני קלקלתי את הקיבה.
היה בסקוויטים.
הבסקוויטים.
וריבה.
וגם ריבה.
והגבינה הצהובה.
איפה היה לנו? זה הפעם הראשונה שיכולנו לאכול.
אוכל כמה שאתה רוצה.
אוכל טוב.
כן.
טוב.
עכשיו רגע, אבל שם גם כן, הזירו אותנו.
חילקו לנו בין חבר'ה שידעו, היו בדיוק.
לסעוד.
וחיזירו אותנו לא לדבר עם כל החיילים,
מפני שיש חיילים כאלה שיכולים לקשקש ולמסור.
להם, למיליטר פוליס, להם פיפ.
ואותנו, את מי הכרנו שם?
את שרגה בן משה, אתה זוכר?
כן, והיה שם, והכרנו גם את, מה שמו?
זר משיב.
זר משיב, בדיוק.
ובחנית.
כן, כן.
זר משיב.
זר משיב, בחנית היכרנו.
ופתאום, כן, מצאנו, איזה, מה זה זה, הרגשנו שם, הרגשנו בשמיים.
שם כבר, הרגשנו, ואחר כך התחלתי.
משם, כן, מיד שוב הביאו אותנו למחנה, איפה זה היה, בברי.
או, דרך, דרך בנציה.
כן, עברנו, אבל מעניין, כן.
בברי זה היה דבור.
אני עברתי דרך...
בנציה, ודרך כל הערים האלו, שם מלמעלה מהצפון, ועד כאילו ככה הייתי שרוב בשביל להגיע, שלא עניין אותי, וחבל, אני פצפסתי.
לא עניין, כן, עברנו, כן, עלו, בכל, כל הערים הקלאסיות של אליפי פיוט.
אמרנו, לא, לא רוצה להסתכל רק...
סליחה, עוד לא הגענו לברי, איפה היינו, ברומא?
אוך, שכחתי.
אה, אה, שכחתי.
שכחת בצ'ינצ'יטה.
אה, בדיוק, בדיוק.
עבירו אותנו לרומא בדיוק, כי אני...
משם, מהערים, הגענו לפני... הגענו לרומא.
איפה, אז שם יש צ'ינצ'יטה, זה מחנה, כמו, כמו, כמו שיש...
תאוליבוד.
תאוליבוד, כן.
שם היו מסלימים את הסרטים.
אבל מה, שם היה, מכל אירופה, היו עשרות אלפים של דפרטנטים.
של... של...
של אילו... זה אילו פליטים שהולכים.
אבל לא רק יהודים.
לא רק יהודים, להפך, היו שם אוקראינים.
מה שהיה שם, כל המחנה שרץ פשפשים וכזה לרועב.
נורא, נורא.
נורא, כן.
ו...
אבל ברומא כבר יצאנו לטייל, אתה זוכר שעלינו יום אחד על הגבעה,
ואמרו לנו שמפרוק, כשנרון שרף את רומא, פה הוא ישב וניגן בכינור,
ומשם מהגבעה...
אז הוא ראינו את כל רומא.
אה, אני הלכתי...
אחר כך הלכנו לקוליסאום.
ו... והייתי על יד ה... על... על יד ה... נו, שמה...
אה...
נו... ידיה קפטה, שמה.
כן.
אז היא שמה... אז מצאתי שמה אישה אחת,
והלכנו לקנות שמה לראות כל מיני...
אז היא פותחה כפי כן את החולצה, מוציאה מגן דבי,
והיא אומרת שהיא יהודיה, ככה, לא הבנו אותה טוב, והיא...
היא דיברה, כן.
אבל הרי אמרנו איזה יהודיה שלא יודעת יידש?
שלא יודעת יידש, כן.
בדיוק.
זה היה, לא הבנו, שלא יודעת יידש, כן.
כן.
אנחנו לא... בבוקרס, פעם הראשונה,
שמעתי שיש בית פרות של יהודי אשכנז וספרדים.
לא הבנו את זה.
שם בכלל לא הבנו בכלל,
מה זה ספרדים ומה זה אשכנזים.
אני זוכר שתפסנו מיטות,
וסידרנו,
ככה, מיטות, סחבנו מכל אחת מזרון,
אני זוכר, ויצאנו בלילה,
לטייל, ברומא, היינו ברחובות האלה,
זה היה, הם הוכחים שם,
פעם בלילה, אני חוזר איזה יום,
זה היה, אני חוזר ב-11, 12 בלילה,
אני רואה אחד ישן על המיטה שלי.
כן.
איזה כל כך, ואחד כזה שעושה בלאגן,
ככה, כזה חזק, הוא כזה חזק, לא, הם פחדו ממנו.
אני לקחתי והפכתי אותו,
עם המיטה, עם המזרון, ככה.
הוא קם, התחלנו להתקוטט, הרבצנו מכות,
ואחר כך הוא קם, לקח את העוגדים,
ועזר והשיאל את המיטה וחזרה.
אמנם הייתי שרוד פה ושם, אבל קיבל מכות.
ומחרד בבוקר, כן, זאת אומרת,
התחילו ככה שוב תזוזה, לוקחים אותנו לבר.
כן, באו חבר'ה, יגידו ושמארגנים לקחו אותנו לכיוון בר.
כיוון בר, זה דרום איטליה.
בתוך עצי זית.
כן, איזה נוף.
והרגלנו כיוון דרום.
ושם עשינו, עסקנו בחקלאות,
ושם הרגילנו צרכי מים, היה אחד מארץ,
ששם עבר קו המים שמוסוליני הביאו מים מהצפון לדרום.
היה שם...
אז הוא עשה חור בצדור,
הכבי ברז, ואנחנו קיבלנו מים.
אני לא זוכר מאין, היה שם מי ים.
איך אני זוכר מי ים?
מברי.
כן, זהו, אבל הביאו שם, בתוך המחנה.
אז שם היינו צריכים לעשות מקלחת,
אז החיילים הביאו לנו מלט,
והביאו חול מלט,
והביאו חול ים,
ואני אמרתי, אני עושה רצפה.
ועשיתי רצפה בשביל מקלחת,
והיום השני, השלישי, הרצפה חול.
וחזרה חול.
ברכה מהמים.
אז או שהמים היו מלוכים,
או שהמלט לא היה מלט.
אבל מה שאני זוכר עוד,
שהלכנו לכפר,
והכפר הזה עבר לגליל.
כן.
הם קיבלו אותנו כל כך יפה.
שם בקפר, ביקשת מים, נתנו לך ייים.
ייים.
כן, הם פחדו מאיתנו.
מים היו...
ודגים היינו אוכלים שם.
שם הם היו דייגים,
עניינים,
מרודים, דרום ניטליה.
דרך אגב,
שם מצאנו את משה גונן ואת דבורה,
ושם הם הכירו.
שם הם...
הם הכירו להם מקודם, אבל הם היו...
הם היו הזוג שם.
את דבורה, אני הכרתי עלו,
כשעברתי מביאלסטוק לשדלץ.
הייתי... תחשיב, הייתי בסמייתש.
ושם מצאתי,
נכנסתי בביאלסטוק, שאלתי,
איפה, יש פה יהודים.
אומר לי, בואי אחד,
תקגו ג'יוו ניהם אונס.
חלק כזה אין אצלנו.
יהודים, הכמל חמה.
הגעתי לסמייתש, שם הייתה קבוצת יהודים,
שמשם הייתה דבורה,
מתי שהיא הייתה מלוקוב, ליצור בסמייתש.
אני לא הכרתי אותה.
והיינו ערב שלם שם,
דומיים, לפני שהגעתי לשדלץ.
אחר כך את דבורה פתאום פגשתי.
משה הגיע לבוקרסט.
טוב.
עכשיו, אז הכרתי בין
משה ודבורה.
דבורה נדביקה אליי.
הכרתי בין משה ודבורה.
כן, שם אפשר.
היה לי להידבק.
היו בנות באמת מסכינות,
שהם רצו קרובה ככה.
הם היו לבד.
אמנם, הרוב היו בנים,
אבל הבנות שהיו שם, הנערות,
כן, אז הם
הם רצו כבר איזה משהו.
נכון.
עכשיו שם היו כמה זוגות מבוגרים.
אתה זוכר את
רזניק?
אם היו בנו רזניקו ו...
כן, הם היו שם.
מה שיש שם,
שם היינו עושים בערבים
שירה בציבור.
היו באים חיילים
מהארץ.
היו באים שם זומרות.
תוכניות.
אז היה לנו אוכל.
רגע, אני גידלתי
גן ירקות היה שם.
היה לנו אוכל, כן.
ו...
פעם החבר'ה יצאו והרביצו
שם לקפריים, היו שם,
הם לקחו לנו את הכפסים, כן.
טוב, אלה הם דברים, זה כבר היה
משהו שחיינו ככה...
לא, לא, לא במתח.
אמנם שכבנו לארץ וכל זה,
זה כבר לא היה חשוב.
עד, ובינתיים עובר,
עובר הזמן, הקיץ,
כן, זה היה חם שם.
שתינו, הלכנו בפרדסים
שם, בב...
בלילות.
וגם בקרמים.
קרמים, הרבה קרמים.
עד ש... וכמובן, שם
כבר היה...
היו לנו... כבר לא היה
מצוקה, אפשר להגיד.
אבל עד שיום אחד התחילו לדבר...
על מתחילים.
מתחילים לדבר.
אז ראשית כל, לקחו קבוצה
סתא שבעים
ואותם שלחו
לארץ במקום חיילים
יהודיים שהיו צריכים לצאת לחופש
שלחו אותם...
והיו עושים קומונה אבליתית?
הקמונה העבריתית POLA.
הם ארכו אימונים כמה ימים ושלחו אותם
דרך מצרים לארץ במקום...
בש nett של חיילים שהיו צריכים לצאת לחופשה.
כן, ואחר כך התחילו
עם הקבוצה... עם הקבוצות.
אני הייתי בקבוצה הראשונה.
אתה היית בקבוצה הראשונה.
היינו 25 איש,
בשירה קטנה,
שאנחנו הגענו שם, היה קרש
מהנמל של הדייגים
אנחנו לסירה
כשוצאתי את היד, היד הייתה
במים, אז אומר לנו
אחד
זוכר אותו עד היום
הוא אומר, עם זה אנחנו
מגיעים להוניגה
עם היד אפליק
אמרתי, פימפר
עם זה אנחנו נשים לישראל
שמעתי כבר שהחבר'ה הישראלים
דיברו
כמה הייתם בבסירה?
26 איש
פלוס 2-3 איטלקים
וזה היה
הגישוש הראשון שהיינו צריכים
לעבור, ואתם אמרו, יש בוקשי ים
ויש
עם ספינה כזו
אפשר להיפגע, אפשר ללמוד
ומתי זה היה?
מה?
מתי זה היה?
זה היה שבוע לפני
עוד עשרה ימים לבית ראש השנה
כן, זה שבוע, זה בערך אותו דבר
אחרי כמה ימים?
אחרי כמה ימים, הייתי בקבוצה השנייה
ואני חושב, על אותו הגודל של סירה
אנחנו היינו
שישים וחמישה
אחר כך היו עוד, אז היינו
שישים ותשע, עוד התפספו
הרבה, לא יודע מאה, אבל הייתה
צפיפות כזאת
שאתה לא, לא היה לך
מקום, שום דבר לעשות
נשאס, הסירות האלה
הם פחות או יותר, הם היו אותו הדבר
לא, לא היו אותו הדבר
איתי היה
נשאמא, סירה
מושה ווטוחופסקי
אני זוכר
שהסירה הזאת
נושאים
ירדנו בתוך המים
קודם פחת, ממתי, זה הפעם הראשונה
שנוצאתי בכלל על הים
שראיתי ים, איפה ראיתי ים
אף פעם לא ראיתי ים
בגנציה ראינו ים
ראינו ים מרחוק, אבל
בשביל לנסוע, להתיישב
בשביל להתנדנת
אז יצאנו בלילה
ואמרו להיות שקט
ולפני שעלינו
לסירה
אז עמדו
אז עברנו דרך שני אנשים
אחד מול השני
וביקשו מאיתנו
הכל מה שיש לנו לזרוב
ואמרו לנו לפני כן
שכל תרמיל זה חצי בן אדם
שני אנשים עם תרמיל
אז יכולים לתרום מקום לבן אדם
שוב זרקתי את התרמיל
מה שאספתי כבר
מה שהיה לי כבר ברכושי
והתמקמנו כביכול גם זמנית
עד למחר בבוקר
נראה גם לנו
אמרו שאנחנו נוסעים
לעונייה גדולה
ונראה מחר בבוקר
עדיין אנחנו עוזבים את הנמל
ונראה גם לנו
התחלנו לנסוע לטלטל בגלים
עם העונייה
הספינה הזאת
הייתה קטנה
ואנחנו לא רגילים
יותר לים
וכל החבר'ה חלו במחלת הים
והתחילו להקיא
ולהרגיש לא טוב
במרכז
למחרת
בעצם
אחרי שראינו
שהיא באה בוקר
והסירה הזאת ממשיכה להפליג
הבנו שזהו
זו היא הסירה
והיא איתה
אנחנו צריכים להגיע
הנכון הוא שאני בכלל
לא הכרתי קודם או נהיות גדולות
אני לא ראיתי בזה
מי יודע מה
זה נראה היה לי סירה די טובה
ואפשר בהחלט להגיע
עד שלאחר יום
התחילו הגלים הגדולים
והרוחות
והיה
ראיתי ממש
ריצינות
שהיו שם השלושה מלאכים
שהם החליפו כל פעם
את הטרנים
והרוח חזקה
ונשטפנו כל פעם עם מים
אמרו לנו לרדת
לסגור את המכסים
ו
לידי היה
משה
וטחופסקי
הוא היה אומר לי
בוא בוא תתקרב אליי
היה כל כך חזקי
היה כל כך חלה שלא יכול היה לזוז
בבוקר
למעלה
על המכר
הסיפון
והוא אומר
קברנו כבר את כל הדברים הגרועים
ועכשיו אנחנו צריכים פה להיות
למחל לדגים פה באמצע הים
התחלנו לטוטל תמיד
ריתובים
מתייבשים
סוחטים את הבגדים
ושוב מתייבשים
היה לי באמצע הים
משהו ש
פעם שהים
נהיה שקט ונהיה חם
אז הורדתי את הבגדים
וקפצתי לתוך המים
לסחוט
התרחקתי איזה
40-50 מטר
מהספינה הזאת
מהצירה
ובאיזושהי צורה
הגעתי בחזרה
התאייבתי כעדיי
סחיתי
איזה רבע שעה
סך הכל
הסיפון בא
היה איטלקי
זה שהיה אחראי
והוא התחיל לצוק עליי
הוא אומר שיש לך מזל
שלא נטרפת
שיש פה דגים טרופים
אני באמת לא הבנתי את זה
ואחר כך הייתי שעשיתי באמת שטות
אנחנו החלגנו
בשביל שבועיים
או שלושה קודם
בשירה עודיוטלית
הקטנה
ספינת
ספינת הידייגים
שאנחנו היינו בערך
בין 28 ל-30 איש
היו חמש נשים
איתנו
ואלנו הייתה שערה
בתוך הים
בין עיי יוון במיוחד
למחרד בבוקר
כשהים התחיל להיות רגוע
רמצנו את עצמנו
קרוב לאי יווני
ולא ידענו איפה אנחנו
ואיפה להמשיך לאיזה כיוון
האיטלקי התחיל לצעוק
לכיוון האיי
והיוונים באו
וחשבו שאנחנו איזה פיראטים
או גנבים
כדי שרוב הנשים היו למטה
היינו איזה ארבע חמישה איש לבעלה
באה משטרה והתחילה לראות עלינו
ושוב ברקנו לבקצה הים
עד שהתקרבנו למקום אחר
היה שם איזה
כנסייה עם כומר
והוא הסביר לנו איפה אנחנו
האיטלקים הסבירו לו
שאנחנו בקיוון צריכים
לכיוון הים התיכון
לכיוון הקרטים
ואז
לפני קרטים
עצרנו את הספינה
המלאכים עשו
ניקוי של המנוע
קשרו יותר
חזק את חביות הדלק
עם חביות המים
והתחלנו
להפעיל ויצאנו
לים הוא פתוח
ככה הפלגנו
ביום השמיני
התקרבנו לארץ
וראינו בבישות הבוקר
את בירות מרחוק
אמרו לנו שזאת בירות
בשעה עשר בבוקר
ראינו את הקרמל ואת חיפה
הסתובבנו כל היום
ועל יד חופי הארץ
עם רשת דייגים
פרוסה מעלינו
והאנגלים בכלל
לא עלה בדעתם
שאנחנו פליטים
שבאים בארצה
בערב התקרבנו
לכיוון
אזור חדרה
בלילה כשיכשיר
בסביבו תשע עשר
אנשי הפליאם חיכו לנו
והורידו אותנו על החור
והלכנו כל הלילה
עד שהגענו לקיבוץ משמרות
ההליכה הייתה גם כן
בצורה דיסקרטית מאוד
עם שמירה משני הזדדים
שפחדו חצינו איזה כביש
ומתברר שזה היה
כביש תל אביב חיפה
ולא ידענו
נעזרנו שלא יגלו אותנו
ואחרי זה היינו שלושה ימים
בקיבוץ משמרות
עד שסידרו לנו תעודות מזויפות
אנחנו
היינו על הים
קצת יותר וזה
אני זוכר
התקרבנו
גם היינו
ליד החוף מול פרדס חנה
וזה היה באמת במשמרות
הבעיה שלנו
היה שאנחנו
ראינו באמת בלילה
אמרו לנו הנה אתם רואים זה
אלה מהאורות מחיפה
ותוך כדי דיבור
אז פתאום
היה איזה מתח
ושארנו
וגילו לנו מישהו ככה גילה
שאסור לנו עכשיו
להתקרב לחוף
ואנחנו
משנים כיוון
ונכנסנו בחזרה לעומק הים
וזה לקח לנו
עוד איזה יום וחצי
מכיוון שאמרו
כן שכל החוף
עכשיו הוא
תפוס על ידי
הצבא הבריטי
בסוף
אני חושב שאנחנו היינו
11 יום על הים
וגם
הגענו למשמרות
שמה נדנו לנו החליפו לנו
קצת בגדים
את המכנסיים הקצרים
ואת החולצה לכל אחד
ומשם ערב ראש השנה
נשלחנו
למקומות אני בחרתי
אמרו שאני
שלו את כל אחד למי שרוצה
לאן ללכת
אמרתי לי אם ללכת
אבל אני מוכן ללכת לקיבוץ
אז בינתיים
אמרו לראש השנה
ראו כבר אמרתי
אני דתי
לראש השנה שולחו אותי
לתל אביב
הדרך לתל אביב
אני כמעט בדרך
מפרדס חנה עד לתל אביב
קראתי את כל השלטים
מה שהיה כתוב בעברית
ערב ראש השנה הגעתי לתל אביב